come on let's take a seat oh my God do
not cry through this interview oh my
slash chat
like first of all we talked about
Frankie Munez
um in the news who is becoming a race
car driver is it true yes that you raced
a car tell me everything well it was a
celebrity Grand Prix race we had two
weeks of training
[Music]
uh we didn't drive those fancy Formula
One cars we had like souped-up Holdens I
think they were but they went fast and
so we had two weeks of training and it
was all women doing it and then we did
the race I didn't win but I like knocked
people out of the way and then
afterwards I was offered to drive
professionally for BMW for their female
team with this German woman yeah and my
agent was like no way we don't want you
to die next week we want you to have a
future now are we happy that this agent
potentially saved our lives or are we
angry that they told us what to do no
I'm fine with it you are I've had a good
run of it I when I heard that story I
got so triggered because when somebody's
like you can't do it yeah you're like
I'm doing it I just I have so much
Rebellion so do I I have to admit but I
knew deep down in myself like probably
not the safest best thing to do I okay
so
channeling Rebellion I've been watching
your show like the power which is based
off the novel I've been I've been doing
research on it it's like talk about
channeling Rebellion will you talk to me
about this show because I have very
strong feelings about this well I think
you know the power itself is this
electricity that girls are suddenly able
to conduct through their bodies so they
able to protect themselves they're able
to feel safe they're able to feel
powerful it's a very empowering show
but it comes about because
out of necessity evolutionary necessity
that women feel so repressed and so full
of Rage that a new
um organ is formed and uh called the
skein and it runs through that
um I personally feel like that this
electricity is like a metaphor for the
power that we all inherently have
whether you nurture it or not and to see
all of those girls like it gave me
goosebumps I found it so moving to see
all of these women girls all different
ages cultural backgrounds experiences
coming into a sense of self and having
some autonomy and feeling free in
themselves like I find it so incredibly
moving and important for women and girls
actually and men to see this to see a
potential balance in in the way
society's structured because we're all
born into a patriarchal world it's
imbalanced it's not fair a lot of us
half of us more than half of us 51 have
been repressed historically for a very
long time and it's changing but not fast
enough and this show just addresses all
of it and more I love the empowerment
and I I think this show has a different
approach to it yeah that is more
superhero more Humane in some ways more
about humanity and and about the anger
in a proper way it needs to be addressed
it's there
um yeah it's it's not about domination
and it also looks at men and how they
respond to it and some of them are
really threatened and it's really
interesting that one person's power
feels threatened like it's not if one
person comes into their power it doesn't
diminish anybody else's power we're all
powerful we should all lift each other
up agree and it's about inclusivity and
it's about balance and equality and
that's really why I wanted to be a part
of it well on a complete opposite
Spectrum do you want to go get in some
onesies cuddle up in the kitchen and go
talk about like your Lucille Ball level
performance
I'm good
[Music]